[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to after the
record where we talk about
whatever you want today we have taran
with us
long time no see so good to be back yes
how long has it been
four years four you counted the videos
i didn't but i just i i know based on
life
life things that have occurred i know it
was four years ago should we all say
four more years
wait four more years a lot has changed
since i have been in this room
updated true well for one we as we were
saying like
conversations have changed in the world
oh just very different yeah
we used to be really different children
we were children children with potty
mouths yeah we
were i was still in my 30s yeah i wasn't
quite a child
four years ago i kept my potty brain
though
um but no i quit youtube and that's all
period i got it
so a lot has changed i i directed a film
that went to tribeca
last year yeah i actually um i haven't
met you before his first time meeting
karen
and i i went to your wiki you have a
wikipedia page yeah
none of us did anyone else have a
wikipedia yeah yeah that's that's
that's i've tried writing my own a few
times me too yeah somebody write us a
wikipedia page please
i'll write your wiki page yes did you
write your own no you can't really
because it's a
anyway there's a whole process that's
crazy yeah i found out about your film
i am human cool right yeah and what's
that about
um it's about the future of man and
machine co-evolution of mana machine so
follow three patients with brain
computer interfaces it's like biomech
kind of stuff biotech yeah wild type
exactly
i saw it it's wonderful i was at the
premiere he was
uh very nicely done thank you so much
yeah for first time director too holy
[ __ ] dude that thing was epic
oh thank you we left out well you also
gave me cancer
what no wait the movie dude the movie
legit
i mean i don't know if the movie gave me
cancer but figuratively and literally
speaking right irritatively and
literally speaking
i was diagnosed with stage three breast
cancer the day that the film premiered
at trademark holy [ __ ]
not diagnosed that day i found the lump
that day and then the next week i was
diagnosed
so i joke that the movie you felt
yourself and you felt a lump i did
did you did you meet robert de niro i
did not
oh okay let's talk about the lump yes
back there
have you seen raging bull
yeah no but yeah the only person to not
pick up on the mic drop
no he did he's just trolling my ass it's
great so you were you were so you're
celebrating
your premiere yeah then what was that
like then to
realize to find the lump and then and
then like
were you were you able to really fully
soak in the success of the
film well i was super sick leading up to
the premiere date while i was in new
york i think all the stress you know
your body finally is like and we give up
and
so i got really sick and my lymph nodes
swelled up and i never had that happen
before and
guys right like on the other side in the
underarm yeah and one of them was the
size of a
of like a large golf ball
and it felt weird and that was the day
of the premiere
and i just but i don't think you found
it i think it found you girl
probably that thing's huge it's so big
but it went i never noticed anything
before that
there was nothing before so it went from
zero to hero
in five seconds and so i got back to la
a few days later and made an appointment
with the doctor i was like this is
strange
and um yeah within three days they
called me and they said you need to come
in you have cancer
oh my god what was that like yeah
i was actually i was in denial i was
like there's absolutely no way
i'm the director i'm 33 i'm 33 years old
i'm super healthy you are this is
stage three how is that possible what
how is that possible that it's like how
many stages
there are four stages fours is like
point of no return kind of
oh stage four there is no cure for
breast cancer oh wow
so i was like all right this is just
yeah it was just a total bizarro
thing and so i said you have to biopsy
it again i wanted to make sure they
didn't swap it or get like a second
opinion or something
yeah yeah smart so i did a second biopsy
it came back again
like nope this is definitely breast
cancer
um and then and then that was it and i
had all these big
plans i was going to be working on a tv
show and i was going to be
which is actually good i needed probably
to take some time off but like
i was going to be speaking um and
performing because i had an ai album
that i had done and so a lot of big
plans for last summer that of course
ai album yeah i'd done this ai album
like a year earlier but because i was
working on the film i couldn't
really perform it yeah it's amazing so
she she talked about this in our podcast
she [ __ ] made an album with an
artificial intelligence
like alexa alexa you would do wedded
with lexa it's not like alexa it's
actually like a software
where you're you're like writing rules
and algorithms for
music oh cool posing music using those
parameters that you set
it's already hard enough to write music
by yourself now you have to tell
something else that
it doesn't have a conscious being to do
the job for you
that's [ __ ] nice it was interesting a
question i've had for you since then i
didn't get to ask you
is is it like creating all the values
almost
predetermining the values like a model
almost and then it kind of populates
that
kind of that's actually one good way of
putting it it sort of depends on the
the algorithm and how it's built because
they're different they're different ones
like i worked with
ibm watson uh google magenta amper
ava so there's like a lot of different
stuff i don't even know what you just
said
so ibm watson by the way does fantasy
football predictions and he's awful
i i can't i can't handle watson i'm i'm
against i'm an anti-watching the ai or
is he a person
ai that was built by ibm they they put
they promote him so much in commercials
he does espn fantasy football
predictions and he's ass
and he does trade uh values like oh you
could trade this player for this player
and it's all
[ __ ] it's all garbage watson sucks at
fancy i'm sorry trying to ruin
everyone's fantasy leagues yes
at any given point when you're doing
this algorithm stuff do you say dore me
no no i mean you could just put that in
the song you don't even speak music to
the
ai no it's like auto-tune code and then
i i
recorded my vocals and wrote the lyrics
for the tracks but it was like basically
the whole track composition was done by
it's amazing i heard i've heard it it's
it's incredible i'll play you guys on
break
like 10 seconds of a song so you can
just hear yeah it was just it was a fun
experiment and i was so excited to like
get it out in the world and do something
about it and then
i i think a lot of cancer patients will
say this like once it hits it's like the
pandemic
everything is your life is over
everything stops everything's on hold
you have no idea adam what did you do
during that time it was
it was challenging i mean i basically
became a full-time cancer researcher
because i was so scared is it still part
of like the
in denial and disbelief really i got it
there's a way out of this i hope you
didn't go on webmd
yeah yeah and i did i did so much
research just non-stop
indeed the first thing that you
shouldn't do is your is your like
statistical chances you know
um because your perception gets all kind
of skewed by that and then you get like
kind of grim about it yeah i mean like
if you're the type of person that goes i
got a 10
chance [ __ ] yeah 10 that's better than
five yeah
yeah i mean you have to just all of the
positives and here's the thing like
breast cancer treatments are so much
better
now than they were 20 years ago but um
once it's in the lymph nodes it's a bit
scarier because it can it can then move
to other parts of the body
so that was yours was it yours was in
the nose mine was
and i had it i had a higher chance than
not that i would have to continue on
chemo for an entire
year after the first round which means
that if i if that was me i would be
right now finishing chemo whoa
a year and a half of chemo so what all
other alternative did you take for not
doing the chemo i did do chemo but i but
fortunately i landed in the in the other
group the one that did not have to
continue doing
my the chemo killed at all oh wow but
you knew people who weren't so lucky
i did and i lost a good friend of mine
two months ago who was also stage three
diagnosed at the same time yeah damn
that's crazy so which is just like
you know was another reminder because
you sort of feel like after you get
through it and i did i did i did chemo
surgery
six weeks of radiation i just i had to
stay on antibody infusions for
through may of this year so there's a
full year of treatment
uh pretty aggressive but i'm still here
and like
hearing that
[Applause]
oh how has your outlook on life like
changed
oh like that crazy was there anyone
where you're like i've been wanting to
tell you this [ __ ] off
that would be cool like you just don't
even hold back well [ __ ] it i might go
anyway so [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they say like i think the the first few
months after i found out that i had pcr
which means
complete pathological response it looks
as though everything is gone
right and the first few months after
that i felt high
like i'm alive and i'm not on
chemotherapy and i can like taste and
see and oh my gosh i'm
alive and it was just so much gratitude
and a little bit of that like
[ __ ] you attitude of just i don't need
to get stressed out about little things
awesome i'm here and that was definitely
a big thing i took with me
i do feel as time goes on i lose it like
it's like
i just start to get caught up in normal
people [ __ ] just like everybody else and
i'm like
why am i worried about my cat right now
like
i don't know whatever the thing is yeah
um but another big thing that happened
was i actually felt a strong
need to want to reconcile with certain
people amazing i have like
emotional reconciliation um with people
in my life who there may not have
been uh like a totally clean break
in whatever the friendship or
relationship was and so i did end up
reaching out to a handful of people
that's cool
i mean you know one thing that we can do
when we're
alone in the house is reconciling people
with people
while we're reconciling with people we
don't want to go out because today's
video is spot to you by
postmates
[Laughter]
and when you're alone at home
reconciling with people you don't want
to go out but right now it's not safe to
go out because of corona and stuff like
that
so i have my friends who who live with
me
and you know i travel a lot and i don't
want to infect them or anything like
that
but what they do for me is when i'm when
i'm sad and alone they'll be like you
want some food and i'll be like yeah
they're like well we're not going to
cook it we're going to order it for you
do they postmate it where they're like
hey when you guys post made it you
deliver to my front door and the back
door
no because we have a dog that bites
everybody so uh
they'll bring it to the front and then
he comes
with his made up face mask and then he
drops it off
and that's it that that's kind of how it
works but i get double post mates right
i get post mate did there and from my
mate
he posts it your mate does the post
my mate aunt does the post yep so if
you're like me and you start
thinking about dinner while you're
eating lunch and you love food but
sometimes getting into the kitchen and
cooking something delicious to eat
just doesn't make it on my to-do list
especially when we have kids sometimes
you just have to time the food while
you're driving back home
that's why we love postmates with
postmates you can get food delivered
without leaving your house
or even opening your front door with the
current state of the world in mind
postmates created no contact deliveries
where they just straight up put it on
in front of your doorstep so you open
the door the person's gone he's bringing
the food
and postmate also offers a pickup option
now
from all of your favorite local
restaurants and it's so important that
we support and uplift our communities
right now a lot of mom and pop shops
need it
and what's the better way than ordering
food and post
mates isn't all just burgers and sushi i
can order anything from toilet paper to
phone chargers
from stores like walgreens and 7-eleven
and a postmate will drop it off right
outside
my front door just download postmates on
ios or
android find your favorites and get
anything you want delivered within
dialogue for a limited time postmates is
giving
our listeners that's you guys five
dollars off your first
five orders that's five five five five
i lost track for your first seven days
to save five dollars on your first
five deliveries download the app and use
code off the record that's code off the
record for
five dollars off your first five orders
so you can look like a baller in front
of your date anything you need anytime
you need it post made it
thank you taryn thank you for letting us
use your experience as a segway okay
i don't know i didn't know what to do
and if you don't mind we would like to
move on now
yeah
yeah
or commercial there's a great intro for
advertisement i still
i still need to know can i just say one
thing though guys sorry one thing to
just close it out
today is actually the one year
anniversary of me finding out
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah no jokes aside i think it's really
beautiful that you um
wanted to go back and and reconcile you
know whatever
thank you keep going because i feel like
it's really healthy
i feel i feel like it's really healthy
because um yeah like you'll carry this
like
heaviness in your heart you know and i
think when you do feel
in that moment where you think maybe
this is it for me like what would i
regret
and it's those conversations did you
ever like go like because you know a lot
of people go oh and i get oh that's when
i'm gonna try heroin
did you ever go like you know what it
seems like
the end of the road is pretty close
let's go skydiving hero and do all the
crazy [ __ ]
when i was in the middle of my rounds of
chemo yeah
it was the it was honestly the worst
feeling i've ever like physically
been through like pain pain just like
i mean you feel like your body's rotting
from the inside out it's i actually on
instagram i made a couple posts where i
went into detail while i was going
through it and people were like thank
you for
like we don't really know what chemo is
like you just sort of see
the hair loss and that's it but it was
so bad and i thought if i had to do this
for another year i couldn't what if i
couldn't i'd rather die what does that
feel like chemo and i felt that way i
mean you never know of course every time
you like come out of it
you know you like you do the thing it
punches you in the gut for a couple
weeks then you start to feel better and
you feel just good enough to go back in
and do it again yeah and so i think
that's just how the
cycle is like a boot camp yeah you're so
strong
that's pretty that's pretty crazy just
explaining it just makes me feel like ow
that's rough would you say that uh you
have a different perspective obviously
you have a different perspective on life
but could you describe like what that is
just for people who have not experienced
anything like that like do you want to
call me one of you [ __ ] little
[ __ ]
out there yeah yeah a little [ __ ] just
complain about little [ __ ] i feel
invincible so i want to hear from
someone who's
actually gone through something like
that oh i
really uh i really
find it hard to not still experience joy
every single day sorry i'm going to get
choked up like you appreciate
it yeah that's dope when i was going
through it i went through
a breakup having to move into a new home
i moved into a new home and then had a
burglary where everything was stolen oh
my god
and then the pandemic hit two weeks
later and um
what the [ __ ] it felt like the terrible
no-good year that just kept getting
worse and worse and worse
but the craziest thing is through all of
it no matter how gut-wrenching it was
i was just so grateful to be here wow
and i just still feel that like it just
even when the burglary happened they
stole my laptop my hard drives
everything
i was like at least i'm alive i
legitimately was like
this is just it stuff make stuff not
hard
but it just it just rolls off of me
differently do you have family uh in la2
they're in kansas so you were just kind
of dealing with everything on your own
or you moved back home
no i was here in l.a because i have such
a great group of friends and the best
medical care in is nla and so they came
out a lot yeah
so they're great dang dude that's crazy
anytime i go through some [ __ ] now i'm
gonna think
what would taryn do yep yeah frankly
she's a [ __ ]
successful actress by the way director
you [ __ ]
conquered a whole field of ai like like
you were doing a lot more in ai than
people even know i know that
uh you beat cancer i mean you are a
tough son of a [ __ ] i'll tell you that
i'll tell you this in the four years of
you going through that i didn't do a
damn thing
i know yep we're uh
still a shitty office like nothing i
caught too cold
babies oh yeah but i didn't do that
right
just another baby i mean how many
billions of babies were born
i was a baby so i try to tell tiff all
the time i'm like you're a mother
congrats [ __ ] three billion people
have done it
this year all right it's not special at
all
it's so funny so yeah you're you're the
i see why though you bring up the past
four years being very different
they're really you've gone through a lot
wow that's crazy
i feel like i've aged a few years you're
wiser though i think i feel like it's
it's wisdom
yeah i feel like you've gone to places
in your mind and emotionally that most
people
don't ever get to go to until like way
later i feel like so
when you're in chemo is there like a
hierarchy like you know like
in jail it's like oh you just a burglar
i'm a killer
like are there different hierarchies of
cancer where you're like you [ __ ] ass
mouth cancer [ __ ]
yes who's the pussiest of them all um
no it's actually funny that you say this
i don't remember where i found it but
there was some kind of cancer stand up
that i watched while i was going through
treatment from some patient who was like
ranting about all of the cancer patients
who have it easy yeah who was it easy
there's like people that will like this
just sounds so bad i don't want to but
i'm just going to say it
um [ __ ] it uh when when you tell people
like what you're going through
and then they're like oh my sister you
know she had she had
you know stage zero pre-cancer cells and
she had to have them removed and
and you want to like be empathetic like
even that what's that even i don't want
to fight
is that like being pre-diabetic it's
just it's as if it's like the
equivalent of you guys saying like you
lost a child
yeah and then someone's like oh we
experienced that when our
little david likes you know got into a
bicycle on the floor
or something right i don't know
her there's just a very different
level of experience that one goes
through and even with
with so they're trying to be nice to
relate no not everyone has to do
radiation it just sort of depends on
where you're at and the treatment that's
required and then
within types of chemotherapies they're
very different some regimens are much
more aggressive
than other regimens um i mean it's
poison but
sometimes they have to really depending
on the receptors and the cancer
because it kills the good stuff and the
bad stuff right that's why it's like so
painful that's what she felt like she's
running from the inside out
yeah i mean you're feeling all of it die
and the smells
like it's like your body rotting like
you smell weird too
yes where does the smell come from like
what what is that
glance any gland any or i mean just like
everywhere you're just seeping it
wow uh when you so they did a whole
cancer stand-up night
like all the patients get together and
so i don't know that's a tough room
some patient did that no some patient
did something
online that i watched and i can't even
remember you you also like developed
amnesia because it's just the whole
thing it's so
crazy but i would find all these
different resources oh there's also
another woman who did a breast cancer
stand up that was really really funny
um but i found i found stand up to be
like my favorite thing and especially
when people made jokes
about cancer for some reason it's a
copying mechanism i loved it
and and so i started telling jokes about
my cancer
um like i went to a party i went to a
party and they were like everybody say
like a fun fact about you that nobody
knows and i was like in a really good
mood and this is
halfway through my chemo is when i was
feeling good and i stood up and i was
like hi i'm tara and i have cancer
so i may not be up here very long
solid dude imagine and everyone was
silent
like should we laugh i don't want to
laugh i thought it was funny
imagine you're doing cancer stand-up
night because you gave me that idea
thank you and
and do you give one of the comedians the
light you think they're gonna [ __ ]
listen
like oh no i got way bigger problems
than your stupid leg
one minute left yeah so that was i mean
that was healing for me to use humor
that's awesome and just be like yeah i
might die like i don't know
laughter is the best medicine
[Music]
you